RIPPED FROM TODAY'S INTERNET
HEADLINES IT'S RAPID REFRESH.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
I JUST HAVE TO SAY, THIS IS
REALLY [BEEP] UP, WHAT HAPPENED
THIS WEEKEND.
THE FBI IS INVESTIGATING A
SUSPECTED HACKING THAT LEAD TO
PRIVATE NUDE PHOTOS OF
ACTRESSES SUCH AS JENNIFER
LAWRENCE AND KATE UPTON BEING
POSTED THE INTERNET THIS
WEEKEND -- IS SUCH BULL [BLEEP]
THIS IS WHY WE CAN'T HAVE NICE
THINGS, INTERNET!
REDDIT HAS STARTED CALLING THE
SCANDAL THE FAPPENING.
WHICH IS AN ADORABLY FUN NAME
FOR "SEX CRIME."
NOW, WE'RE ALL WONDERING WHO'S
BEHIND THIS, BTU DON'T WORRY,
CNN'S TECH DESK HAS IT ALL
FIGURED OUT.
>> DO WE EVEN KNOW, WHO IS THIS
4CHAN PERSON OR WEBSITE?
>> HE MAY HAVE BEEN JUST A
SYSTEM ADMINISTRATOR WHO KNEW
HIS WAY AROUND AND HOW TO HACK
THINGS.
>> CHRIS: WHO IS THIS 4CHAN
PERSON ANYWAYS!
IS HE FRIENDS WITH THAT REDDIT
GUY?
THE ONE WITH THE ANTENNA ON HIS
HEAD.
BY THE WAY I'M STOPPING BY THE
STORE LATER, SHOULD I -- SHOULD
I PICK UP ANY SNACKS FOR THE
LEMON PARTY TONIGHT?
I GOT LOUD, I'M SORRY.
COMEDIANS, PLEASE GIVE ME
ANOTHER QUESTION POSED BY CNN'S
TECH EXPERT.
DAVID KOECHNER, GO.
>> MY SON SIGNS HIS E-MAILS
C U NEXT TUESDAY, WTF.
DOES THAT MEAN HE'S GOING TO SEE
ME NEXT TUESDAY OR WEDNESDAY,
THURSDAY, FRIDAY?
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
POINTS. WELL PLAYED.
JON.
>> IF I DON'T HAVE ANY FLOUR OR
BUTTER HOW DO I ENABLE COOKIES.
[LAUGHING]
>> CHRIS: UH, I'VE HAD TOO MANY
COOKIES. I BETTER GO EMPTY THE
CACHE.
POINTS FOR JON DALY.
THE LEAK INSPIRED BY THE WAY
INSPIRED THE HASHTAG
#IFMYPHONEGOTHACKED, WHERE USERS
POSTED THEIR MOST INTIMATE
PHOTOS, LIKE THIS ONE FROM AT
DARK MEAT HOOK.
HOW DID THAT GET OUT?
HOW DID THAT GET OUT.
I DON'T MEAN THE PICTURE.
I MEAN THE CORN DOG.
COMEDIANS, WHAT EMBARRASSING
THING WOULD YOU POST AND HASHTAG
#IFMYPHONEGOTHACKED, NICOLE
BUYER?
>> ME PRACTICING FRENCH KISSING
ON MUFFINS.
>> CHRIS: NICE.
POINTS.
HANG ON A SECOND.
ARE THESE REAL MUFFINS, OR
EUPHAMISTIC MUFFINS.
>> OH, THEY'RE REAL MUFFINS.
YOU POP THE TOP OFF AND GET IN
THERE.
>> CHRIS: OKAY, OKAY OKAY. NICE.
POINTS.
JON DALY.
>> STANGLE-BATING TO BING
COMMERICIALS.
>> CHRIS: STANGLE-BATING?
>> THAT'S WHEN YOU PUT A TIE OR
A BELT AROUND YOUR NECK --
>> CHRIS: I KNOW WHAT IT IS.
>> AND YOU J OFF.
YOU J OFF.
>> THEN IT'S BING AT THE SIDE.
>> CHRIS: SO NOW WE GOT TWO
TERMS FROM YOU TODAY,
STRANGLE-BATING AND J OFF.
BOTH TV-FRIENDLY, GUYS.
TV FRIENDLY, JON DALY.
POINTS.
>> CHRIS: OF COURSE THE CLOUD IS
TAKING HEAT FOR THE SECURITY
BREECH.
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE PEOPLE ARE
TRYING TO PROFIT FROM IT.
>> HEY, DON'T MIND ME. I'M UP
HERE IN THE CLOUD.
YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE IS UP HERE?
A THOUSAND NAKED PICTURES OF
YOU.
NO MATTER WHO YOU ARE SOMEONE IS
CRANKING THEIR PORK ROD TO YOU
RIGHT NOW.
LUCKILY THERE IS A NEW CLOUD TO
PROTECT YOU.
ME.
I'M DICK CLOUD.
I'LL HANG ONTO THEM FOR YOU IN
ALL THE CLASSIC JERK
MATERIAL HIDING SPOTS.
LIKE A FOURTEEN-YEAR-OLD'S
MATTRESS.
AND A PILE OF LEAVES IN THE
WOODS.
AND MANY MORE. SOME PLACES I
WON'T TELL YOU ABOUT.
TRUST ME DICK CLOUD WITH YOUR
SECRETS.